well we're on the 14th floor of the
Beijing hotel here in the heart of the
Chinese capital a location which has a
very particular place in history but
let's go out onto the balcony and look
first of all at the quite fantastic view
the Beijing skyline laid out before us
and you can see those iconic roofs of
the pagodas that make up the Forbidden
City here in the heart of the Chinese
capital and as we move around you can
see the southern end of the Forbidden
City the Tiananmen Gate where that
portrait of Chairman Mao has hung for so
many years and just to the south of that
is Tiananmen Square and Tiananmen Square
is why this particular location is so
important because 25 years ago exactly
it was from these balconies that foreign
journalists filmed images which are now
among the most famous in the world tank
man he stood just down there in what is
now a sea of traffic 25 years ago it was
simply a sea of tanks a column of tanks
at the front of which he stood defiantly
and he managed to stop them and since
then many of the photographers who have
reminisced about the pictures that they
took have talked about how at the time
they saw him moving out into the middle
of the road and they were irritated they
thought he was gonna ruin the
composition of their shots which was
supposed to be shots of tanks and then
they realized he was a man he was out
there to protest out there to stop the
tanks and potentially get shot and
killed and they realized all of them
that they had iconic images that were on
the front pages of nearly every single
newspaper globally the following day in
terms of the incident itself well the
journalists were here because they were
covering the visit the state visit a few
weeks before June the fourth of Mikhail
Gorbachev he was here to meet the
Chinese leaders for that reason
journalists have been given access to
the country rare access because foreign
journalists were not particularly
welcome they came here
mr. Gorbachev left the journalists
stayed they stayed because they reckoned
that the protests that were taking place
at the time peaceful protests might turn
nasty but of course it wasn't just here
in Tiananmen Square and in Beijing it
was in cities right around the country
protests
gathering momentum and on June the 3rd
June the 4th 1989 the patience of the
ruling Communist Party had run out an
order came from on high that the
military who'd been standing by for so
many days should move in and move on the
protesters and so they did and the
Tiananmen Square massacre as it's now
known took place and to this day it is
an event which simply isn't discussed in
China it's quite staggering really you
won't get people within China to talk
about it of course the Communist Party
remains in power the country has changed
we all beyond all recognition but no one
mentions June the 4th